je suis un millier indigné par le
procédé
indignés par le mensonge
indignés par l'outrance l'amusé il doit
y avoir des limites à la calotte hier
faisait circuler une rumeur fantaisiste
sur une grave maladie qui m'aurait
atteinte sous entendu je ne serai plus
capable d'assumer mes fonctions
aujourd'hui on rapporte une histoire
abracadabrantesque ont fait parler un
homme mort il ya plus d'un an
on disserte sur des faits
invraisemblable qui ont eu lieu il ya
plus de 14 ans on exhume un
enregistrement fait il ya plus de quatre
ans et dont le journal lui-même qui
publie ces propos les qualifie d'
invérifiables et de sans valeur
juridique
et tout cela comme par hasard
trois jours avant un référendum visant à
améliorer le fonctionnement de notre
démocratie
alors je vous le dis c'est à lauga ces
allégations sont indignes et mensongères
voilà pourquoi je demande que ces
éléments soient transmis à la justice
afin que la vérité balaye la calomnie